En el año 2009 me invitaron a participar de un proyecto
que la Universidad Nacional de San Martín tiene dentro de la Unidad 48,
para coordinar un taller de escritura.
El servicio penitenciario les cedió un terreno en el fondo de la cárcel
y ahí mismo construyeron el edificio del centro universitario.
La primera vez que me reuní con los presos,
les pregunté por qué estaban pidiendo un taller de escritura
y me dijeron que ellos querían poder poner en un papel
todo lo que no podían decir y lo que no podían hacer.
Yo ahí decidí que quería hacer entrar la poesía a la cárcel.
Entonces les dije por qué no trabajábamos con la poesía,
si sabían lo qué era la poesía.
Nadie tenía ni idea de qué era realmente la poesía.
Y además ellos me plantearon que el taller no era solamente
para los presos universitarios, sino que también abarcaba
a toda la población de presos comunes.
Y entonces yo dije para empezar este taller yo necesito
alguna herramienta que tengamos todos.
Y esa herramienta era el lenguaje.
Entonces teníamos lenguaje, teníamos taller. Podíamos tener poesía.
Pero lo que yo no calculé fue que la desigualdad también vive en la cárcel
y había muchos de ellos que no tenían ni siquiera un primario completo.
Muchos no manejaban la letra cursiva, apenas una imprenta.
Tampoco escribían demasiado fluidamente.
Entonces empezamos a buscar poemas cortos, muy cortos, pero muy potentes.
Y empezamos a leer y leímos un autor y leímos otro autor
y al leer esos poemas tan cortitos, entre todos se fueron dando cuenta
de que lo que hacía el lenguaje poético era romper
una determianda lógica y armaba otro sistema.
Romper la lógica del lenguaje es también romper la lógica del sistema
al que ellos están acostumbrados a responder.
Entonces apareció un nuevo sistema, unas nuevas reglas
que los hizo entender muy rápidamente, pero muy rápidamente,
que con el lenguaje poético iban a decir absolutamente lo que ellos quisieran.
Dicen que para ser poeta hay que bajar alguna vez al infierno.
Y a ellos infierno les sobra. Les sobra infierno.
Una vez uno de ellos dice: "En la cárcel no dormís nunca.
Nunca se puede dormir en la cárcel. Jamás podés cerrar los párpados".
Y entonces, yo hice así como ahora,
un momento de silencio y les digo, chicos, eso es poesía, eso.
El universo carcelario está exhibido, lo tienen en la mano.
Todo esto que dicen, que no duermen nunca.
Esto destila miedo. Todo esto no escrito. Todo esto es la poesía.
Entonces empezamos a apropiarnos de ese infierno.
Y nos metimos directamente, de cabeza, en el séptimo círculo.
Y en ese séptimo círculo del infierno, tan nuestro, y tan querido,
aprendieron que las paredes podían ser invisibles, a hacer gritar
a las ventanas, a que nos escondiéramos dentro de las sombras.
El primer año que había terminado el taller convocamos
a una pequeña fiesta de fin de año como se hace
cuando se realiza un trabajo con tanto amor.
Uno quiere celebrar y hacer una fiesta.
Convocamos a familiares, amigos, autoridades de la universidad.
Lo único que tenían que hacer ellos era leer un poema,
recibir su diploma, aplausos y eso era toda nuestra sencilla fiesta.
Lo único que yo quiero poder dejar es el momento en que esos hombres,
a veces enormes al lado mío.
O muchachos jovencísimos, pero con un orgullo tremendo,
sostenían su papel y temblaban como chicos y traspiraban
y leían su poema con la voz absolutamente quebrada.
Ese momento a mí me hizo pensar mucho que seguramente a muchos de ellos
era la primera vez que alguien los aplaudía por algo que hubiesen hecho.
En la cárcel hay cosas que no se pueden hacer.
En la cárcel no se puede soñar, en la cárcel no se puede llorar.
Hay palabras que están prácticamente prohibidas como la palabra tiempo,
la palabra futuro, la palabra deseo.
Pero nosotros nos atrevimos a soñar y a soñar mucho
porque decidimos que iban a escribir un libro.
No solamente escribieron un libro sino que además lo encuadernaron.
Eso fue a fines de 2010.
Hicimos una segunda apuesta y escribimos otro libro.
Y encuadernaron otro libro.
Eso fue hace poquito, a fin del año pasado.
Lo que puedo ver semana a semana es cómo se van convirtiendo
en otras personas, cómo se van transformando.
Cómo la palabra les da una dignidad que ellos no conocían,
ni siquiera podían imaginar.
No sabían que esa dignidad existía y que podía ser de ellos.
En el momento del taller, en ese infierno amado que tenemos, todos damos.
Abrimos las manos y el corazón y damos
lo que tenemos lo que podemos. Todos.
Todos por igual.
De esa forma uno siente que al menos muy poquitito
está reparando esa tremenda fractura social que hace que
a muchísimos como ellos los espera la cárcel como único destino.
Recuerdo un verso de un enorme poeta, un gran poeta,
de la Unidad 48 de nuestro taller, Nicolás Dorado:
"Tengo que conseguir un hilo infinito para coser esta gran lastimadura".
La poesía hace eso. Cose las lastimaduras de la exclusión.
Abre puertas. La poesía hace de espejo.
Inventa un espejo, que es el poema.
Ellos se reconocen, se miran en el poema y escriben
desde lo que son y son desde lo que escriben.
Para poder escribir hace falta que ellos se apropien del momento
de la escritura que es un momento extraordinario de libertad.
Tienen que entrar en la cabeza y buscar ese pedacito de libertad
que nunca, que nunca nadie les puede quitar al momento de escribir
y que también eso les sirve para comprobar que la libertad es posible
aún estando dentro de la cárcel y que la única reja que tenemos
en nuestro maravilloso espacio es la palabra reja y que todos,
en nuestro infierno, ardemos de felicidad
cuando se prende la mecha de la palabra.
(Aplausos)
Yo les conté mucho sobre la cárcel, mucho sobre lo que experimento
cada semana y lo que disfruto y me transformo junto con ellos.
Pero no saben lo que a mí me gustaría que Uds. pudiesen sentir, vivir,
experimentar aunque sea unos pocos segundos
lo que yo cada semana disfruto y me hace ser quien soy.
(Aplausos)
"El corazón mastica lágrimas de tiempo
ciego de ver esa luz
oculta la velocidad de la existencia
donde reman las imágenes
lucha, no se deja ir.
El corazón se agrieta bajo miradas tristes
cabalga en tormentas que riegan fuego
levanta pechos aminorizados de vergüenza,
sabe que el método no es solo leer y seguir
también desea ver el infinito azul.
El corazón se sienta a pensar las cosas,
lucha por no caer en lo común,
intenta aprender a amar sin herir,
respira el sol dándose coraje,
se entrega, viaja a la razón.
El corazón pelea entre ciénagas,
bordea la línea del inframundo,
cae sin fuerzas y no se entrega a lo fácil
mientras pasos desparejos de embriaguez
despiertan,
despiertan la quietud".
Soy Martín Bustamante,
estoy preso en la Unidad 48 de San Martín,
hoy es mi día de salidas transitorias.
Y a mí la poesía y la literatura
me cambiaron la vida.
¡Muchas gracias! (Aplausos)
CD: ¡Gracias!
(Aplausos)